dólar estable o libre libanesa
fluctuante Esto es lo que tienen que
decidir los compradores locales a la
hora de ir al supermercado desde 2019
Líbano se ha visto sumido en una
dramática crisis económica que ha hecho
que el valor de la moneda local la libra
libanesa caiga en picada debido a su
valor inestable el precio del dólar
supone un alivio para algunos ciudadanos
libaneses para mí es mejor que los
precios se fijen en dólares así los
supermercados no cambian los precios
todos los días si un producto tiene un
precio de $2 estadounidenses podemos
estar seguros de que se mantendrá igual
y no subirán y bajará el precio de un
día para otro fijar los precios en
dólares estadounidenses es mejor
sin embargo para otros Este cambio
supone una dificultad en su vida
cotidiana me sorprendió ver que todos se
cotizaba en dólares estadounidenses no
encontraba nada en libres leonesas ahora
tengo que calcular los precios una
molestia para los ciudadanos en febrero
el ministro de economía a misa Lama
anunció que los supermercados podrían
empezar a fijar los precios de los
productos en dólares mientras que los
compradores podrían elegir la moneda que
deseen utilizar para pagar salam añadió
que las tiendas tendrían que Mostrar
claramente el tipo de cambio que
utilizan cada día la unificación de los
distintos tipos de cambio del Líbano es
una de las condiciones previas
establecidas por el fondo monetario
internacional hace casi un año para que
el país se convierta en una economía de
Mercado y así poder acceder a un rescate
de 3.000 millones de dólares